biggest study ever on the pay Gap I
think it was done by Harvard basically
looked at Uber drivers in America the
big reason was the biggest because he
had so much data Uber obviously has so
much data they looked at the Ping and
they were like well women are getting
paid less at Uber how does that make
sense because it's obviously all
automated what a great way of studying
male or female Behavior to work out what
is in this Gap and there's three things
in the Gap the first was men drove at
different times a night so men would do
the graveyard shifts early mornings
we're getting paid more they would want
to do that women less so second was that
men were more likely to stick with the
platform for longer so they had more
experiences and they benefited from
experience makes sense of any job and
the third reason which is 50 of the Gap
was that men just drive faster
so drive a little faster guys then
you'll close that Gap that shows it
wasn't discrimination that's causing the
pay Gap in Uber it was just heavy right
foot different types of behavior and I
guess we could have discussion of what
shapes that behavior but we need to
start that conversation with it's not
discrimination at least an Uber
different types of behavior yeah but
when it comes to my wife it is
discrimination because when she gets a
female driver she is often tempted to
reject very sexist in that way